tonight we take a look at an incredible
effort made by members of our community
to help those in hospice just in time
for christmas
sasha loftus joining us now live near
jones and sunset with the story you'll
only see on 8 news now
[Music]
denise and brian these are the stories
we all need to hear right now
a mother and daughter duo heard that the
patients at this hospice care here
needed some help just in time for
christmas so they got to work
and their efforts brought more joy than
anyone could have imagined
many say christmas is a time for
miracles
[Music]
[Applause]
after weeks of work around the clock a
local family
made this one happen it took a village
and
you know the vegas community really came
through amber garcia and her daughter
ayanna castro
organized this amazing donation event
they gathered things like blankets
pajamas fuzzy socks
and handwritten cards dropping them here
at infinity hospice care
on friday we just reached out to all of
our
networks of friends and this is what
happened
170 patients who've had to spend months
alone due to covid19
can now all expect gifts under the tree
for the first time
in six years it's the first time
since i've been with this company in six
years that we've had
every single patient walk away with
something
20 20 has been tough this is so great
but nikki ellis of infinity hospice care
says
this gesture has the power to turn it
all around
whatever they went through back in the
past they could put that behind them
and they can see all the wonderfulness
that's going to come ahead
the community may not be able to show
its appreciation
up close but this tribute means so much
more
we want them to feel the happiness and
warmth and no matter how much
sadness they felt every single person
here
will leave this earth knowing they are
loved
that we care about them that they are
not alone
thanks to amber ayana and of course the
entire las vegas community every patient
here at infinity hospice will receive
things like pajamas socks
anything you can really imagine those
christmas cards just in time for the
holiday
the volunteers here will wrap them and
get them out a week from today
for now reporting live sasha loftis 8
news now